if you were to leave your legacy mikey
how is it that you want to leave your
legacy man i want people to remember me
for
for not you know not babysitting a title
not
you know ducking guys not going dif
around i won't
be remembered for for the guy that fire
everybody when everybody was still at
the prime
you know not catching people on the way
out and not trying to
take loads of everybody i mean nobody
fight everybody
and and and took on the biggest
challenges they don't even let you fight
everybody even if you want to they don't
even let you fight the right guy
it's crazy right that's that's all the
politics and
business that keep those from happening
you know but with me i just want to
fight everybody that's that's available
biggest five biggest challenge that's
how i want to be remembered
as a legend mike what advice would you
give mikey in his career
no listen um mikey's the legend now you
know what i mean
mikey knows everything he's been doing
has been perfect
you know i mean and he's even an
overachiever i never knew that he could
fight that welding
against those big opponents thank you
thank you
i mean i'm very impressed with the um uh
fight
thank you that really uh impressed me
and for for someone that that
like myself that started at
featherweight you know people wouldn't
imagine that i'd be fighting you know
at welterweight ever and i'm i'm still
holding my own there you know so
i i yeah i thought that after that i was
a little crazy though to be honest with
you but you didn't you came
everybody everybody you know it's it's
gutsy yeah definitely
it's in the heart you know it's it's
yeah no brains are involved
yeah you have to man you have no brains
are involved
to actually i remember i remember i
remember wishing you luck for that fight
i remember saying you messed up
that message i was like man i said he's
gutsy because i went up a weight class
yeah
and i was the underdog yeah i ended up
knocking that dude out yeah you know
what i'm saying i remember that
so it's like you know i was rooting for
it because thanks
man that's that's another way class
that's the there hasn't been too many
no no no that's not another weight class
with the most vicious guy in that way
god crashed whoa come on that's what it
is that's what it is
no thank you thank you yeah i mean we
i'm actually i'm down we're down to
fight anybody
you know biggest five biggest challenge
you know the fights that people say i
shouldn't be taking that's
that's what i'm gonna be taking just to
show everybody that i can that's so
that's that's really what i want to be
remembered for